merkel oder seehofer wer setzt sich
durch das thema heute in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer
meine gäste im studio gute lage ist bei
uns korrespondentinnen im
hauptstadtstudio des deutschlandfunks
und zuständig dafür rechts und
innenpolitik frank meyer journalist und
kolumnist beim magazin cicero beobachtet
seit vielen jahren die bundesrepublik
mit der distanz des gebürtigen
schweizers gerd landsberg
hauptgeschäftsführer des deutschen
städte und gemeindebundes und
schließlich professor hans vorländer
politikwissenschaftler an der
technischen universität in dresden und
direktor des dortigen zentrums für
verfassungs und demokratieforschung naja
das resümee des heutigen tage sind
bundestag aber auch in den
unionsfraktionen war da viel lärm um
nichts wenn man bedenkt dass es ja
tagsüber einen moment so aus als könnte
sowohl die fraktionsgemeinschaft der
union als auch die koalition zerbrechen
also es war sicher nicht viel lärm um
nichts
es geht immerhin um das thema das die
meisten menschen auch emotional berührt
wie auch immer sie sich dazu einstellen
also es ist ein ganz wichtiges thema das
an einem wichtigen ort diskutiert
nämlich auf der ebene der regierung und
es wird mal offen diskutiert das finde
ich ganz toll das ist eine ein zeugnis
demokratischer kultur sag ich mal böse
auf dass ich ziemlich lange gewartet
habe das mal da offen diskutiert wird
dass man sich die dinge sagt und schaut
wie man weiter kommt
es geht ja um die zurückweisung an der
grenze für asylbewerber oder flüchtlinge
die ja in andere länder und registriert
sind die hier schon mal abgelehnt wurden
oder die den asylantrag in anderen
ländern läuft in der csu lesart ging das
immer ganz einfach ist das so diese
zurückweisung lässt sich das so einfach
bewerkstelligen
zuerst einmal nach dem masterplan den
horst seehofer vorlegen wollte geht es
tatsächlich um leute die asyl beantragt
haben in einem anderen staat das sind
schon mal viel weniger als diejenigen
die sich woanders haben registrieren
lassen
die zurückweisung sollte auch noch nicht
jetzt stattfinden sondern erst wenn die
obergrenze die so nicht genannt wird von
etwa 200.000 menschen erreicht sein
sollte das sind schon mal große
unterschiede die heute unter den tisch
fielen das ist schon mal eine
schwierigkeit was die frage betrifft auf
die zurückweisung so einfach möglich ist
nein so einfach ist sie sicher nicht
möglich
es geht die dublin-verordnung und es
gibt unterschiedliche lesarten die ganz
herrschende lehre ist der meinung dass
man in deutschland entscheiden muss
wohin man zurück schiebt das wäre dann
eben zum beispiel italien oder
griechenland möglicherweise aber
wahrscheinlich in der regel nicht
österreich und das ist eben das land wo
die leute landen wenn man sie einfach wo
sie aber auch meistens dann hin
zurückgeschoben werden wenn sie nach
deutschland das gar nicht ein dass man
vor länder
dieser streit der wurde ja von alexander
dobrindt und auch von horst seehofer
jetzt ganz bewusst entfacht und man hat
ihn auch eskalieren lassen
der zeitpunkt warum sucht die csu gerade
jetzt den konflikt die landtagswahlen
sind ja noch ziemlich genau vier monate
hin die heiße wahlkampfphase hat noch
nicht begonnen
es geschieht mit einer vehemenz als
ginge es um leben und tod
ja ich habe die csu es sicher selbst
unter druck gesetzt und der
innenminister auch er wollte am dienstag
seinen masterplan vorstellen und dann
stellte sich heraus dass da doch punkte
drin waren die der kanzlerin nicht
gefielen
anscheinend war es nicht abgesprochen
sie war auch nicht vorher an scheint
hinreichend gut informiert worden und
deshalb kam jetzt diese situation so
dramatisch einher wie wir das heute
haben erleben können und nun muss
natürlich seehofer liefern
das ist eine situation in der sich jetzt
hinein bugsiert hat aus der kommt er
kaum
so gut heraus dass nachher die csu
gänzlich unbeschädigt ist es sei denn
man macht es und setzt die regierung aus
landsberg die fehler die 2015 gemacht
worden sind flüchtlingswelle
zuwanderungswelle insgesamt sind ja
890.000 menschen in diesem jahr nach
deutschland gekommen die könne nicht
rückgängig gemacht werden aber wie sieht
heute eine glaubwürdige
flüchtlingspolitik aus die diese fehler
von damals vermeidet sie vertreten ja
eine organisation die sich mit diesen
fehlern wenn sie denn passieren auch
noch viele jahre beschäftigen muss also
das ist richtig wir haben nach wie vor
natürlich die herkulesaufgabe der
integration
ja aber ich finde die ganze diskussion
die jetzt geführt wird
ich will es mal vorsichtig höflich
formulierend ungewöhnlich wir haben ganz
andere probleme wir sind meilenweit weg
von 200.000 flüchtlinge dieses jahr nach
deutschland kommen werden
es hat eine vielzahl von maßnahmen der
bundesregierung gegeben als
rechtsbestimmungen sind verzerrt worden
der deal mit der türkei es gibt viel
mehr mittel für die flüchtlingslager im
libanon
all diese dinge sind viel wichtiger als
die minimale frage wen kann ich an der
grenze woran abweisen das ist juristisch
etwas umstritten
wir haben jetzt schon zwölf 1700 fälle
wo leute zurückgewiesen werden man muss
fairerweise sagen wohin zurückgewiesen
wenn das andere land sieht dann nicht
nimmt also ich habe das gefühl hier wird
ein kleiner baustein den ich nicht für
so bedeutend halte genommen um jetzt
eine grundsatzdiskussion zu führen ich
würde mir eine andere diskussion
wünschen
warum schaffen wir es nicht die
maghrebstaaten zu sichern
herkunftsländer zu machen warum können
wir unser asylrecht nicht so machen dass
es schneller geht
stattdessen diskutieren wir aus meiner
sicht in einer intensität an der
falschen stelle
das heißt das thema zurückweisung ist
gar nicht das entscheidende
wann wird man bausteine relativ kleinen
angriff klein aspekt der asyl- und
flüchtlingspolitik auf ich denke das ist
schon wichtig ist ja auch nur ein punkt
den man jetzt durch den widerstand gegen
seehofer so hoch gespielt hat können sie
haben mal vor allem warum macht man
daraus ein theater bitte also aber das
ist wichtig sie haben sie angesprochen
die
fehler die gemacht wurden wie man lange
nicht gerettet hat der hauptfehler war
dass man eine attraktivität für
deutschland aufgebaut hat und für mich
geht es wenn ich seehofer die csu die
urteile darum eine gegenteilige wirkung
zu haben quasi eine abschreckende
wirkung dass diese maßnahme ist in der
sache vielleicht gar nicht so wesentlich
aber was sie ausstrahlt sie strahlt das
gegenteil der willkommenskultur aus und
das ist irgendwo richtig und nötig dass
meine ganz persönliche meinung dass man
weiß so leicht wie es ging geht es nicht
mehr
aber sind ja heute von allen seiten der
union ja eigentlich hohe erwartungen
geweckt worden nicht nur von der csu
dann auch von der cdu wir bekommen das
problem in den griff die csu möchte ist
mit einem nationalen alleingang machen
angela merkel in den nächsten 14 tagen
auf der europäischen ebene wenn diese
erwartung nicht erfüllt werden dann gibt
wir für alle der schuss nach hinten los
die erwartung können kaum erfüllt werden
die erwartungen die die csu geweckt hat
können glaube ich nicht erfüllt werden
zumindest dann nicht wenn wir wirklich
eben um die umsetzung des masterplanes
reden dann geht es eben nicht darum dass
nun in nächster zeit horst seehofer die
anordnung trifft bestimmte leute sollen
zurückgewiesen werden durch die
bundespolizei sondern die dann geht es
darum dass man den plan fast irgendwann
in weiterer zukunft möglicherweise so zu
handeln und diese erwartung wurde heute
nicht gedeckt wurde ein völlig falsches
bild aufgebaut und so wichtig es ist da
gebe ich ihnen völlig recht offen zu
reden ist das die falsche art das ist
eben gerade nicht offen das war heute
ein spiel über bande auf verschiedenen
ebenen wo eben nicht offen diskutiert
wurde worum es wirklich ging
insofern können diese erwartung meines
erachtens kaum befriedigt werden
auf der anderen seite wird es angela
merkel auch nicht gelingen innerhalb von
zwei wochen nun diese bilateralen
abkommen auf den tisch zu legen
diese erwartung wird allenfalls
befriedigt werden in der weise dass sie
positive signale vorweisen
in zwei wochen das ist auch nicht das
auf das alle gewartet haben
in der csu wird da im prinzip weiter
strapaziert werden
vorländer wir haben jetzt schon gehört
dass anderen die falschen akzente
gesetzt werden soll abschreckend wirken
möglicherweise aber ist das gar nicht
umsetzbar weder politisch noch rechtlich
seit dem herbst 2015 bei den umfragen
wenn man fragt was ist das thema das für
sie am wichtigsten ist wo drückt der
schuh stets auf platz 1 die einst die
flüchtlingspolitik obwohl ja seit dieser
zeit die zahl der flüchtlinge die nach
deutschland kommen erheblich
zurückgegangen sind wir werden auch
diese obergrenze von 180.000 bis 220.000
im koalitionsvertrag festgelegt worden
sind dieses jahr gar nicht reißen wie es
aussieht wenn nicht etwas um folgendes
passiert warum bleibt dieses thema
trotzdem für die bevölkerung auf der
agenda
das ist in allen europäischen staaten ja
so dass das migrations thema das thema
ist das am höchsten gespielt wird was
die menschen aber vielleicht auch am
stärksten bewegt und welches sich auch
eignet um zu polarisieren
das ist ja es ist überall mit unsichtbar
mit am tisch
sie sitzt das ist sozusagen der große
weiße elefant im raum der immer dort ist
und die systeme eignet sich eben auch
für polarisierung und das ist jetzt auch
innerhalb der union ja ganz deutlich
geworden das war ja eigentlich seit 2015
die ganze der die ganze zeit der fall
das ist hier sehr unterschiedliche
einschätzungen gab und man hat dann auch
angesichts der wahl im letzten jahr die
position von merkel mehr oder minder
gestützt wenngleich aus bayern immer
doch erhebliche rufe nach obergrenzen
kam auch hier gab es ja schon diese
fraktion innerhalb der union
und das ist nun aufgebrochen und es ist
so aufgebrochen das jetzt tatsächlich
wie auch söder und andere sagen eine
entscheidung kommen muss und diese
entscheidung würde ja dann bedeuten dass
wenn seehofer und söder
gewinnen merkel ihre gesamte politik
dementieren müssen niedrigen eine
demütigung eigentlich auch der kanzlerin
was sie überhaupt nichts zu lassen kann
und deshalb kämpfen ist das der
eigentliche grund für diese für diese
diesen unversöhnlich scheinenden streit
dass es hier um einen machtkampf geht um
eine ausrichtung der beiden zehn
parteien ja ich glaube ich glaube es ist
ein machtkampf an diesem symbolisch sehr
aufgeladenen thema und werden könnte ja
sagen
gut das ist alles im rahmen des
wahlkampfes in bayern so habe ich die
ist für die csu ja auch aber es ist
gefährlich weil sich dahinter auch eine
spaltung in der gesellschaft und jetzt
auch in der union auf tod und die wird
noch einmal befeuert und darin liegt
meines erachtens die große gefahr diese
auseinandersetzung das ist kein
gewöhnlicher streit streit ist immer gut
ist meint wie gut dass jetzt die
differenzen aufgebrochen sind und
thematisiert werden aber es muss auch
lösungswege geben und die sind im
augenblick so nicht erkennen konnte es
ist ganz bestimmt
dieser persönliche also der persönlichen
hintergrund der dahinter steckt und die
verhärtung aber ich glaube es steht auch
wirklich in der sache etwas ganz anderes
noch dahinter
herr söder hat heute den georteten
multilateralismus für beendet erklärt
und das ist die gegenposition zudem zu
dem versuch eben die europäischen
verfahren zu stärken den
multilateralismus in europa in dieser
schwierigen situation mit entwicklung
wie wir sie in polen in ungarn jetzt
vielleicht auch in italien haben
da sind ganz grundlegende unterschiede
wie man in europa weiter miteinander
umgehen muss und das betrifft jeweils
diesen weg und deswegen glaube ich dass
da beide sich auch weiter verhört das
heißt dass die quasi die csu in
sogenannte visegrad lager der
osteuropäische staaten mehr abdriftet
mit ihrer position wir wollen uns das
gleich mal anhören wir haben noch zwei
töne vorbereitet zunächst markus söder
heute morgen vor der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
im bundesratsgebäude wir müssen in
deutschland endlich klare entscheidungen
treffen zu lange sind wir bei der frage
der flüchtlingspolitik immer wieder von
kompromiss zu kompromiss gehalt ohne
grundlegende klare entscheidungen zu
fixieren wir müssen die lage in
deutschland wieder in griff bekommen
deswegen ist wichtig dass wir das nicht
auf die lange bank schieben und von
einem europäischen gipfel zum anderen
hecheln in der hoffnung dass dann die
europäer uns irgendeiner form etwas
geben was ich selber in für sich selber
anders umsetzen
ja er von gipfel zu gipfel hecking da
meinte er natürlich die bundeskanzlerin
der bayerische ministerpräsident in
seiner äußerung die ja genau das
gegenteil
da die gegenteilige strategie jetzt
anwenden möchte nämlich auf europäischer
ebene ein ergebnis erzielen
auch sie hat sich heute nachmittag nach
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wo sie
teilweise dabei war geäußert ich
persönlich halte die illegale migration
für eine der großen herausforderungen
der europäischen union und glaube
deshalb dass wir nicht unilateral
handeln sollten dass wir nicht
unabgestimmt handeln sollten und dass
wir nicht zu lasten dritter handeln
sollten ja die europäerin angela merkel
gegen markus söder der sich eigentlich
eine position zu halten macht die man
auch bei sebastian kurz bei viktor orban
und bei kaczynski findet richter etwas
auseinander
in der union ich denke zunächst mal ist
das was frau merkel sagt eine vision
dass die eu eine gemeinsame strategie
findet in der flüchtlingsproblematik
übrigens flüchtlingsproblematik das
schon das wort problematisch geht um
einwanderung ist ein teil flüchtlinge
aber immer mehr es ist dass einwanderung
dass diese einwanderung problematisch
problematik von der eu mal unter
kontrolle gebracht wird hat das dauert
noch das dauert noch auch die idee von
frau merkel die lateralen mit abkommen
mit spanien italien frankreich
griechenland österreich zu etwas zu
kommen ist auch eine zukunfts sicht das
ist auch nicht da es wird schwierig sein
warum eigentlich geht man nicht davon
aus man kann das eine tun und das andere
nicht lassen
man beginnt damit dass man sagt so wir
werden jetzt streng an der grenze wie
deutschen welt streng an der grenze wir
machen das bilaterale parallel arbeiten
wie dann das löst auch bewegung aus die
sagen dann ja da müssen wir was tun
ich möchte noch sehr ich möchte noch
durch jahren aber ich möchte nochmals
hinzufügen was ich aus meinem land
gewohnt bin wenn seine regelung nicht
gibt dann macht ein kanton eine regelung
und der andere endlich sind vielleicht
ganz verschieden in ihren regelungen und
es entsteht etwas so wird das auch in
europa entstehen müssen dieses planspiel
besitzen zusammen und wir finden die
lösung das hat bis jetzt nicht
funktioniert kantonalisierung europas
nach schweizer vorbild das sind kantone
gut die nation natürlich ist doch schön
ich aber etwas an geschaut dass er noch
mal klar machen
es gibt eine bestimmte entwicklung des
kommen jetzt auch immer mehr flüchtlinge
aus afrika das großenteils
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge die sind weder
als mitbewerber weil da unten sehen wir
ja weder asylbewerber die politisch
verfolgt sind noch sind es flüchtlinge
nach der genfer konvention also
bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge oder
kriegsflüchtlinge
und es ist auch keine kontrollierte
einwanderung in den arbeitsmarkt herr
landsberg
die haben schon vorhin gesagt diese die
kommunen fangen das alles auf jetzt
nicht sagen dass sie die suppe
auslöffeln aber sie haben auf jeden fall
die probleme der einwanderung der
zuwanderung der migration und darauf
folgend der integration quasi zu lösen
wie sieht die situation aktuell
eigentlich in den kommunen aus was die
flüchtlingsunterkünfte angeht was
integrationskurse angeht haben dass die
meisten kommunen in deutschland im griff
kann man sagen dass ging irgendwie hin
oder
geht dass da irgendwie außer wanderland
wir kriegen das schon irgendwie hin aber
das reicht eben nicht ich bin immer ein
einfaches beispiel die sprachkurse es
macht keinen sinn in einem sprachkurs
einen syrischen akademiker mit einem
analphabeten aus afrika gemeinsame
sprache beizubringen
das haben wir heute gerade weil der im
kanzleramt angesprochen da brauchen wir
an das system wir brauchen viel mehr
sprachkurse gebrauchen sie auch früher
das ist jetzt nicht eine kommunale
aufgabe wir wollen das mit organisieren
auch die frage bei der integration wie
bringe ich die leute in arbeit wir haben
ja das system die kommen dann dauert es
relativ lange dann kriegen sie
sprachkurs 1 sparkurs 2 dann kommt die
arbeitsmarkt orientieren sie nach
dänemark die meist ganz anders die sagen
vom ersten antrag arbeiten vor mit dass
arbeit auch wenn die letztlich natürlich
nur hilfstätigkeit machen nachmittags
sprachkurs und nach ihren darstellungen
funktioniert das sehr viel besser also
über diese dinge müssen wir auf der
kommunalen ebene mit der bundesregierung
reden das kostet natürlich auch geld das
dauert zeit wir haben nach wie vor
nehmen sie das beispiel köln 40 hotels
angemietet um leute unterzubringen als
ich sagt ganz klar noch mal so eine
welle
das halten die kommunen nicht aus und
die flüchtlingspolitik spaltet natürlich
die gesellschaft das haben sie gesagt
aber ich würde gerne noch mal einen
schritt zurückgehen
es wird jetzt immer so getan also die
politik hat versagt was sie alles falsch
gemacht haben ich darf nur daran
erinnern
die begeisterung der deutschen
bevölkerung übrigens auch gerade in
münchen wo er die meisten ankam
das war ja als hätten die alle marathon
erfolgreich gelaufen und wie immer in
seiner bewegung das gibt jetzt ist das
gekippt jetzt kommen die ängste da
spielt die silvesternacht all diese
dinge spielt eine rolle
und jetzt mal wieder die politik muss
man wirklich mal ganz schnell was machen
wir sollten wirklich mal ehrlich sein
das thema migration und flucht wird uns
auch die nächsten 20 jahre beschäftigen
und das ist der erste noch länger das
ist der erste punkt ehrlichkeit so
zweitens es ist ein irrglaube dass ist
schnelle lösung gibt ganz egal welche
zeitung mit welchen großen buchstaben
das ankündigt also muss man versuchen
dafür zu werben und es ist ja auch nicht
so weil sie das ein bisschen angedeutet
haben dass nichts geschehen ist
natürlich ist der schutz der
außengrenzen der eu nicht perfekt aber
es doch viel besser natürlich gibt es
die hotspots dass die eu hat fast 500
millionen menschen
wir können nicht erwarten wobei ihnen
auch mal in den bundesländern uns nicht
einig sind
die geht einmal in die
merkel und sagte dass man das wird so
nicht funktionieren dass wir jetzt noch
mal über zurückweisung an den grenzen
also menschen die sie schon in europa
sind und jetzt nach deutschland wollen
das stichwort ist ja gerade gefallen
auch mit frontex und mit dem schutz der
aussengrenzen ist das sozusagen der
stein der weisen ist das der bereich wo
europa nicht nur handeln muss sondern
auch effektiv handeln kann
es ist eine der säulen wo europa handeln
muss schwer handeln kann und wo aber
etwas passieren muss und worauf also
wieder hat er gesagt wir sollten das
erst mal selbst in die hand nehmen
lehrer den schutz der aussengrenzen kann
ist zwar richtig aber ich war mal wir
sind ja abhängig auch von den anderen
europäischen ländern
gerade das kontext dass das gemeinsam
alles geschieht und der grund warum das
gemeinsam geschehen muss ist dass die an
den außengrenzen liegenden staaten ist
alleine nicht schaffen und das ist
gleichzeitig der grund warum wir auch
sonst die gemeinsame europäische aktion
brauchen weil sonst eben die länder an
den außengrenzen diejenigen sind die am
ende mit den leuten alleine dastehen
deshalb braucht es in beiden bereichen
das gemeinsame handeln und ich glaube
herr kurz schon dass er das ordentlich
voran bringen will und ich glaube auch
dass es ganz allgemein wunsch in europa
gibt dass frontex ausgebaut wird zur
richtigen grenzpolizei
das sind die bereiche in dem man sich
einigen kann wo man sich nicht einigen
kann das ist die flüchtlings verteilung
und andere fragen
aber diese fragen da sehe ich eigentlich
gar nicht so russischen studenten wenn
das grenzregime in europa wirklich
funktioniert die außengrenzen
einigermaßen gut geschützt sind es eine
gemeinsame asyl konzeption
möglicherweise ein gemeinsames asylrecht
gibt in europa wenn es bei der
verteidigung verteilung relativ gerecht
zugeht wenn man sich dann doch ein nicht
weil man weiß man muss zusammenstehen
und kann nur gemeinsam handeln dass man
dann vor allem auch diese illegale
einwanderung das macht ja viele leute
irgendwie kirche dass man diese illegale
einwanderung auch effektiv unterbinden
kann
nein also wird man
nicht gänzlich unterbinden aber die
aufgabe besteht hier auch darin wege für
die legale arbeitsmigration zu eröffnen
und das ist beispielsweise etwas was nur
europäisch geht und da kann deutschland
zwar voran gehen es gibt die eine oder
andere idee die auch entwickelt wird
aber das muss in europa gänzlich
einheitlich auch so sein
und dann gibt es eben möglichkeiten
durch entsprechende maßnahmen menschen
die in europa arbeiten wollen auch hier
hin zu holen ohne sie den schleusern
auszuliefern das ist glaube ich die
entscheidende gesichtspunkt dass andere
ist sozusagen die asyl die
asylproblematik die davon wieder
deutlich zu trennen ist man glaubt man
muss das sowieso die asylproblematik die
kriegsflüchtlinge kriegsflüchtlinge und
die arbeitsmigration deutlich kategorien
ich habs gerade auch gesagt der
asylbewerber flüchtlinge und legale
arbeitsmigration und alle anderen sind
ja dann eben das sind eben viele die
jetzt gerade in libyen warten sind ja
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge die ja unter
keine dieser drei kategorien fallen ja
das wissen wir ja nicht so genau ob sie
in alle ärger großteil wir werden bei
arbeitsmigration mehr anstrengen dass
das wissen wir nicht nur da muss es
natürlich auch partnerschaftliche
verträge mit diesen staaten und regionen
geben um das einigermaßen steuern zu
können und das kann nur europa als
gemeinsamer anstrengungen wenn die
migration geregelt wird und man sagen
wir holen leute die wir brauchen können
dann holt man den arzt oder den
akademiker und denjenigen der analphabet
ist kommt nicht rein so das hätte man
auch schon lange eigentlich machen
können nicht sage europäische lösungen
dauert länger das ist ich bin in grünen
der europäer der letzte schweizer der
glühende nur damit das bekenntnis hier
fällt aber es ist so aber das dauert und
mehr eines wird man wahrscheinlich nie
hinkriegen denn ich glaube in einem
punkt täuschen wir uns dass man es
verteilen kann
ich glaube letztlich web im jede nation
und einwanderung
ist etwas derart wie sage ich nation
nationen bezogen etwas persönliches wird
die situation für diese menschen dass
die leute sagen wollen über die
regierung oder wenn sie die schweiz in
der eu ist über die direkte
volksabstimmung das volk selber
bestimmen wollen wie viel und wie das
ist das ganz große problem also man kann
regeln machen das kann ordentlich sein
man kann überzeugungsarbeit macht aber
ich glaube letztlich bleibt es immer
auch dessen kultur oder eine nation ich
will das gar nicht das schreckliche wort
heimat brauchen das ja verpönt ist aber
es ist eine kultur und diese kultur die
ihr habt ein empfinden für sich und für
fremde
das wird weiter funktionierende mensch
ändert sich nicht die verhältnisse
vielleicht schon
also ich muss sagen sie haben gerade
heftig gelegt als herr meyer sagte man
kann ihn nicht verteilen
das problem ist ja dass in europa ganz
unterschiedliche der attraktive
zielländer gibt deutschland gehört er zu
den attraktiven zielländern muss auf
diesem gebiet auch etwas passieren das
wäre mal der mut deswegen bin ich auf
ein europäisches asylrecht das doch klar
ein europäisches asylrecht wird sich
nicht an deutschen standard messen
können das werden die anderen staaten
nicht mitmachen und wenn wir die
diskussion führen wir wollen mich so
viel menschen die unbedingt warum wollen
die alle nach deutschland doch nicht
weil deutschland sehr schön ist sondern
weil wir die leistung besser sind also
müssen wir uns europäisch verständigen
und ich glaube auch wenn es zu einem
wirksameren schutz der aussengrenzen
käme und den punkt aber noch nicht
angesprochen nennen wir uns ein bisschen
mehr noch um die fluchtursachen kümmern
ich will mal ein beispiel nennen wir
hatten libanesische bürgermeister bei
und sie wissen der libanon hat viel mehr
flüchtlinge als wir hier
prozentual und dann habe ich denen
dargestellt was es bei uns für leistung
gibt zunächst mal an sich geglaubt und
dann habe ich gesagt nein das ist
tatsächlich so
und dann haben sie gesagt also für die
fünf milliarden
dann nehmen wir in 800 tausend syrer ab
dass das klingt jetzt mal kam aber man
muss sehen dass für das geld was wir
hier ausgeben wie er den
herkunftsländern den leuten
möglicherweise ein viel besseres leben
die sind doch nicht alle glücklich hier
in deutschland
aber das wort flucht ursachenbekämpfung
für ein ja viele im mund ein
parteifreund von horst seehofer gerd
müller ist ja der
entwicklungshilfeminister der hat sich
das ja sozusagen auf die fahnen
geschrieben
aber wenn wir feststellen dass die
integration jahrzehnte dauert und die
migration uns noch lange beschäftigen
wird wer auch immer mehr generationen
dauern wird die migration weil immer
wieder menschen kommen oder immer mehr
nachkommen
das thema flucht ursachenbekämpfung ist
ja auch ein generationenproblem das kann
man das den politikern so leicht über
die über die lippen aber geschehen ist
da ja relativ wenig da sieht man schon
daran dass wir nach wie vor afrikanische
staaten mit unserer unfaire
handelspolitik benachteiligen als nur
ein beispiel
also wenn man das etwas wenn man das
nicht als sind in vielen generationen
denkt sondern etwas kurzfristiger denkt
dann wird man sicherlich unterscheiden
müssen solche sachen wie sie genannt
landsberg das wirkt natürlich
unmittelbar also 2015 ist in dieser
massivität ausgelöst wurden die
bewegungen die der stattgefunden haben
weil es in den flüchtlingscamps nicht
mehr genug zu essen gehabt
das ist eine art von flucht
ursachenbekämpfung die ganz unmittelbar
wirkt und das hat sich eben auch
gebessert wie viel man durch
entwicklungshilfe in der frage erreicht
das ist tatsächlich umstritten und das
sind ja die fragen die die dann eben zum
teil auch schwarze afrika betreffen
jetzt ganz abgesehen von von solchen
handelns fragen die wir sicherlich mehr
mit in den blick nehmen müssen bei
solchen fragen
ich wollte gerne nur noch auf eine sache
antworten die frage ob wir gerade den
syrischen arzt nach europa bekommen und
und wie man wie man das regeln kann
die finde ich gehört hier nicht her wir
sind hier bei der flucht frage und da
wären wir zum beispiel bei der frage ob
wir noch kontingente möglicherweise
erweitern wollen die wir ja schon haben
die andere frage ist die das
einwanderungsgesetz ist und das ist aber
mit word dokumenten nicht auf
europäischer ebene verhandelt das ist
nun eine sache die tatsächlich das
gehört zusammen
das gehört absolut zusammen dass sie an
die diffusion der seit vielen jahren
oder sie sagen was ihr herz gehört aber
ich habe für mein land ein
einwanderungsgesetz gehört hin denn das
ist heute ist alles vermischt völlig
unklar wer ist wer
erstmals sprechen ja es wird immer in
der öffentlichkeit gesagt es gibt kein
einwand aus jetzt selbstverständlich
gibt es einen ein gesetz es gibt das
gesetz zur steuerung und begrenzung der
zuwanderung so das kann man nicht gut
finden aber da sind berufsgruppen
aufgelistet die werden in einer
rechtsverordnung jedes jahr wieder neu
festgelegt und diese leute auch
außerhalb der eu können nach deutschland
kommen jetzt kann man sagen es muss
besser werden aber in der öffentlichkeit
immer so zu tun
wir haben gar keine regeln natürlich
haben geredet werden vielleicht die
falschen regel nur da muss ich aus
kommunaler sicht noch mal sagen wir
haben ja eine enorme zuwanderung aus eu
ländern
im letzten jahr war das über 800.000
dann haben auch die flüchtlinge dazu wie
viel mehr dürfen es dennoch sein also
sie müssen ja auch denken wir haben
jetzt schon wohnungsnot wir haben nicht
genug schulen wie haben nicht nur noch
kitaplätze also das ist so eine
abstrakte diskussion mit dieser
zuwanderung ich habe nichts gegen
zuwanderung ich war damals an der
zuwanderungskommission und auch nichts
gegen ein punktesystem nur das ist nicht
die lösung die das problem ist das
wohlstandsgefälle die leute sehen im
fernsehen auf dem iphone wie toll wir
hier alle leben und trotzdem natürlich
beklagen und dann sagen da will ich hin
würde ich um es genauso machen so also
glaube ich dass es nur einen mix von
maßnahmen geben kann
wir haben darüber gesprochen
fluchtursachen bekämpfen außengrenzen
schützen und einen rechtsraum möglichst
europäisch zu schaffen das klingt
schwierig und ist auch nicht von heute
auf morgen zu machen
aber der begriff ist ja nicht gut
besetzt ich halte das für alternativlos
das heißt dass wir über der anlass der
sendung eigentlich jetzt geschaffen
worden ist zurückweisung an den grenzen
oder an der deutschen grenze für die die
nicht berechtigt sind hier einzutreten
da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
auffassungen wer das sein darf und wer
oder wer rein darf ist da die völlig der
völlig falsche ansatz
jetzt muss ich noch mal widersprechen
das ist nicht eine frage
das ist deswegen nicht ganz weil das
natürlich eine wirkung auslöst die
diskussion die jetzt in deutschland hier
läuft die wird doch in den anderen
europäischen ländern gesehen und
natürlich fürchten nichts mehr als dass
deutschland seine grenzen zu gemacht
denn dann werden noch mehr in italien
haben und noch mehr in spanien noch mehr
in österreich insofern hat das eine
gewisse politische wirkung aber bei dem
baustein diese flüchtlingsproblematik im
griff da ist es nicht so bedeutet aber
darauf setzt die kanzlerin dem sie sagt
wenn wir jetzt ernst machen wir haben
noch zwei wochen zeit uns mit euch dass
wir uns mit euch einigen über eine
regelung in europa und ansonsten wird
das was horst seehofer hier im
masterplan festgelegt hat dann bei uns
auch umgesetzt werden
ich weiß nicht ob diese aktion der csu
die verhandlungsposition deutschlands in
europa wirklich verbessert hat weil nun
klar ist dass angela merkel unter druck
steht und sie sich möglicherweise auch
vieles einlassen muss
bei den zwei wochen geht es ja um etwas
anderes bei den zwei wochen geht es um
bilaterale vereinbarungen um die dublin
abwicklung zu erleichtern mit den
jeweiligen staaten da geht es nicht so
ist davon eigentlich sollen
antragsteller wo man zuerst dass man den
griechen dagegen betreten hat
zurückschicken dahin zurück schickt
jetzt aber das ist ja ein teil dieses
problem zu sagen da gibt es dann leute
die ja eigentlich woanders ihren als
wieder antrag stellen müssten oder
vielleicht sogar gestellt haben und das
ist nur das land deutschland kommt es
ist nur der versuch jetzt an dieser
kleinen stelle zu flicken das sind diese
bilateralen abkommen die großen fragen
sind ohnehin nicht in zwei wochen
verhandelt da zeigt sich die
österreichische zukünftige rats
präsidentschaft zuversichtlich dass man
da bis ende des jahres möglicherweise
weiter kommt das ist sicherlich schon
ambitioniert aber das ist sicher keine
frage von zwei wochen vielleicht noch
einen hinweis zwischen spanien und
frankreich gibt es solche bilateralen
vereinbarung also was ganz neues wäre
das nicht zwischen frankreich und
italien ja auch aus wobei ist da soll
bis zu 85.000 im jahr
im letzten jahr von frankreich wieder
zurück
diesen worten zwar nach italien zwischen
deutschland österreich und das glaube
ich 7000 woran liegt er woher kommen
diese unterschiedlichen zahl der nach
deutschland wollen ja auch sehr viele
kommen dass die grünen sorgen und zurück
manchmal an der grenze in deutschland ja
dass 2016 2017 war das 7000 glaube ich
gewesen und an der italienisch
französischen grenze und das sind hier
eben deutschland handhabt das eben so
dass es diejenigen sind die nicht sein
dass sie asyl beantragen wollen oder die
sagen dass sie durch deutschland durch
reisen wollen
und das sind die leute die tatsächlich
nicht eingelassen werden das ist eine
völlig andere voraussetzungen als wenn
ich sage ich habe eine vereinbarung
darüber dass ich diese zurückweisung c't
regeln im gegenseitigen einverständnis
erleichtere dann kommen andere zustand
dass sie noch andere gruppen
herr professor vorländer ich will etwas
was mir wichtig sein die diese debatte
wo sich jetzt zwei protagonisten
wirklich fast schon feindlich
gegenüberstehen was mir wichtig scheint
sie haben gesagt wenn jetzt seehofer
quasi siegen würde man würde das tun
ich höre man will es ja dann schon tun
wenn die andern nichts du aber dann wäre
das eine schwere demütigung der
kanzlerin haben sie gesagt demütigung
für mich ist ein politiker oder eine
politikerin die ihre fehler auf den
tisch legt und sagt okay machen wir es
war falsch ich mache hier diesen schritt
keine demütigung ich würde den größten
respekt zollen
ich habe solche sachen schon erlebt und
es wirkt auch in der bevölkerung wird
das gut wenn man es denn wirklich machen
kann und nicht wie die kanzlerin es bis
jetzt macht auf schleichwegen wo man es
nicht sie hat ja viel korrigiert viel
einsicht gezeigt aber es nicht gesagt
man muss dazu stehen dass bestehe ich
nicht
da gebe ich ihnen recht dass durch die
entsprechende asylgesetzgebung in 15 und
16 hat es ja solche verschärfenden
maßnahmen gegeben
das hat merkel selbst auch im wahlkampf
eigentlich nicht wirklich thematisiert
aber der hintergrund ist natürlich
will ich dass sie das auch ein bisschen
auf genötigt wurde und sie einen anderen
ansatz hat sie wollte erstens diese
humanitäre aktion auch im nachhinein
nicht wirklich selbst dementieren
sie ist für die aufnahme von menschen
die aus kriegsgebieten und bewegliches
gebieten kommt das ist eindeutig so ihre
position und sie möchte eine europäische
lösung da gibt es eben doch sehr große
unterschiede es geht ja weil sie sich
jetzt so verhakt haben die d2 ist damit
eigentlich auch noch sehr viel mehr
gemein nämlich ob man einen multilateral
europäischen zugang zur
problembewältigung hat oder ob man einen
bayerisch nationalen zugang zu diesen
problemen hat und die einzelstaatliche
lösungen wie er sich das seeufer oder
sogar vorstellen ist nicht die lösung
des problems sondern ist selbst teil des
problems und da hatte merkel glaube ich
den langfristig besseren ansatz den sie
auch jetzt verteidigen muss das sind
unterschiedliche konzeptionen die der
bewältigung dieses problems und die
lösung seehofer oder führt nicht
wirklich zur großen lösung die wir in
der migration aber das heißt ja auch in
der praktischen politik jetzt hat ja
seehofer angekündigt er lässt sich von
der csu absegnen dass er jetzt als
minister da einfach maßnahmen ergreift
was man immer ganz übersieht und was wir
auch in dieser runde noch gar nicht
diskutiert haben die koalition in berlin
besteht aus drei parteien die spd ist da
ja noch gar nicht gefragt worden die
musste ja auch mitmachen
es wurde ja schon süffisant aus der spd
vermerkte dass das thema zurück weiß ja
gar nicht im koalitionsvertrag stünde
ist das jetzt ein unionsinterner streit
aber der möglicherweise ja gar keine
auswirkung auf die praktische
regierungspolitik hat das stimmt ich
wollte nur auf ihre frage hin noch
einmal darauf hin
der bundesinnenminister lässt sich vom
parteivorstand der csu in münchen
nochmal absegnen wie er an den deutschen
grenzen agieren will das völlig schon
bemerkenswert ein ansatz wäre das
amtsverständnis die spd finde ich immer
noch erstaunlich leise
in der frage kann natürlich auch bequem
zurücklehnen und erst mal abwarten
könnte aber auch finde ich etwas
deutlicher eine eigene position
vertreten
aber natürlich im zweifel wird nicht
zweifelt die spd würde mindestens
mehrheitlich das so nicht mitmachen und
insofern ist die frage was dann
regierungshandeln wäre noch eine andere
nur der weg den horst seehofer ja wählen
soll zumindest wenn man söder und
dobrindt folgt wäre ja dass er eben im
alleingang handelt und wenn man
tatsächlich sagt das ist ressort prinzip
dass es sache des bundesinnenministers
dann hätte da auch die spd nichts zu
sagen dann wären wir bei der frage der
entlastung durch angela merkel was ihr
hier gar nicht ist wird er gar nicht
anders übrig bleiben als den
bundesinnenminister dann zu entlassen
denn dann wäre es ja das habe zwar
gesagt sie
respektieren jeden der oder jede die
fehler eingesteht aber hier geht es ja
auch um eine demontage des amtes
wenn sie das als etwas an sie das in
ihre richtlinienkompetenz fällt weil sie
die richtlinien auch in der
migrationspolitik bestimmt und besteht
weiterhin bestimmen will dann in der tat
müsste sie ihn entlassen wenn dann zählt
das argument der ic ressortzuständigkeit
eben nicht und weil es jetzt uns so eine
so grundsätzliche bedeutung bekommt wird
sie sich diese frage ausstellen müssen
sie wird die nicht einfach davonkommen
lassen können also die sache ist
eigentlich noch komplizierter man könnte
sie nämlich durchaus auf den standpunkt
stellen dass das die anwendung des
rechts wir haben den paragraph 18
asylgesetz da steht drinnen da steht
wörtlich drin leute sind zurückzuweisen
wenn sie woanders den antrag gestellt
haben jetzt sagen die mehrheit der
juristen dann so richtig dargestellt
das wird überlagert von den europäischen
regeln also muss sie alle ins land
kommen und dann muss das geprüft werden
das ist aber nicht so unstreitig es gibt
auch juristen das anders sehen und sie
wissen ja in solchen situationen wird
wird möglicherweise ein jurist im
innenministerium sagen das hat mit der
richtigen kompetenz gar nichts zu tun
das ist die anwendung deutschen rechts
so dann kann man darüber natürlich ein
rechtsstreit führen aber wie gesagt die
das ist nicht so eindeutig wenn jemand
nachgewiesenermaßen neben einem sicheren
drittland wir sind nur von sicheren
drittländern umgeben einen asylantrag
gestellt hat und registrierte sagt er 18
asylgesetz eindeutig der ist
zurückzuweisen
also nicht so einfach wieder haben ich
würde gerne noch am ende der noch zwei
minuten
zwei politische fragen stellen sie habe
das ganze schon angesprochen dass sie
verwundert sind das die eine partei über
das handeln eines ministers entscheidet
zeigt das dass horst seehofer in seiner
eigenen partei auch ein getriebener ist
und gar nicht mehr das heft des handelns
in der hand hat ich fand heute schon
auffällig dass herr dobrindt verkündet
was herr seehofer tool wird nachdem der
parteivorstand gesprochen hat ich habe
den eindruck dass er sehr ein
getriebener ist wir hatten ja ganz am
anfang über diese differenz zwischen
seiner position oder csu-position
worüber wir eigentlich reden gesprochen
dass das so untergeht liegt glaube ich
auch daran dass es nicht in erster linie
horst seehofer ist der hier spricht und
ich glaube ja mal nächste woche was
passiert da wir haben ja im untertitel
wer setzt sich durch seehofer oder
merkel gibt es nächste woche noch eine
koalition aus cdu/csu und es gibt mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
irgendeinen kompromiss
und dann wird interpretiert wer das
gesicht verloren hat was mich wenn ich
das sagen darf erstaunt ist dass die
ganze tonalität die aus den medien über
diese diskussion die da jetzt entfesselt
es kommt mit einem bedauern mit einem
fast seinem entsetzen dass das jetzt
stattfindet wir leben nicht nur in einem
europa brauche in einem europa wo alles
in bewegung ist und das ist das was
deutschland jetzt erfasst
deutschland war mit seiner macht seinem
wirtschaftserfolg den ich auch genießen
italia hier steuern seit zwölf jahren
also
aber es war eigentlich konnte sich
zufrieden geben mit dem was ist und
jetzt kommt die bewegung von außen und
deutschland das ist das erste mal es
nimmt bewegung auf dass es keine
innerparteiliche geschichte das ist eine
geschichte die auch für europa etwas
ausstrahlt deutschland kommt also in der
europäischen realität an die diskussion
geht weiter wir werden sehen was aus der
dieser regierungskrise ausgelöst durch
den streit von cdu und csu wird in der
nächsten woche gesicht einer
führungsrunde natürlich auch mit wachem
auge dran bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]